i'm here with luanna who is a mom of
three
and we've been talking about her female
support group we're talking about
divorce
divorce with kids and i actually was
able to bring in two fantastic women
um to add to her support group uh
please meet money expert carmen rita
wong
and relationship therapist dr rg alan
wilson
hi guys
[Applause]
so carmen in this support group um
that we're building in addition to
luana's already existing
support group of female friends you are
also
a divorced single mother yes ma'am
i am can i ask your advice in your
specialty of finance do you have any
advice for luana while she is navigating
this divorce
one of the most important things you can
do when you go to the table
to finalize things financially is
keeping those kids in mind
one of the best pieces of advice that i
got when i was going through my divorce
was my attorney saying to me
you have more power than you know
and that's at the financial table if you
keep those kids in mind if they're your
north star
then you can get some stability and
security in your life whether it's
their education health insurance
whatever it is
always have them in mind so you're
coming at the table
with great energy positive energy love
for them
but you're a little bit of a mama bear
you know what i mean
dr rg is there any way to emotionally
prepare yourself
for signing divorce papers and this
question comes with
god i wish i had been able to ask you
that myself
well thank you for having me drew and
and lana i have to say that you
are such an amazing inspiration and it's
true that divorce is kind of like a
theft
oh timmy think of divorce like a death
but the truth is that
it's the death of the lifelong
relationship that we dreamed of and so
focus on radical self-care in action
we can turn that pain into power luanna
but in order to turn it into power we
have to appreciate the process
so we can walk in our purpose that's the
goal
can i ask you a question luana do you
have
any ability to have someone watch your
kids for the day
that you sign your divorce papers
because looking back i wish i had done
that for myself
faking it for them was hell i'm not
gonna lie
and if i had just had a window of a day
to process and be around
friends and just not have to put on that
front
it was very difficult no now that you
mention it maybe i will get a babysitter
maybe i will go out to a lunch or dinner
with my
girlfriends or make it just about me and
just you know do whatever i would i
would love to do
but that's an amazing idea i didn't even
know that i
i couldn't even think of that myself we
actually have a little surprise for you
uh luana um there were a few things that
some of your very best friends wanted to
tell you
hi luanna i just wanted to let you know
how much i love you
i love you you were there for me from
everything through
the death of my mother dan being
deployed to iraq
i admire your strength and tenacity over
the last couple of years i've seen you
overcome
so many obstacles in life you've taught
me that no matter how hard life gets
you can always bounce back and better
than you were before
you've risen above all the things that
you've been through you really
are one of the bravest and most
inspiring women
that i have ever met the last few years
have not been
easy there have been plenty of
challenges the road is bumpy as hell
i know that i'm there for you no matter
what always
don't ever change who you are and i'm
always here for you i
am here to support you in anything and
everything i'm not going anywhere bad
girls for life
i love you oh my gosh
that was amazing thank you so much
so much girlfriends that is who you need
to be with on the day you sign those
papers get a babysitter
and if i could have a get in the
delorean and do it differently
i would not be like in front of my kids
that day
oh no thank you for that recommendation
i totally will plan it that way
i want to thank uh luana with all of my
heart for having
what is a very difficult discussion but
trying to figure out how to navigate it
is everything and i really want to thank
dr rg
and carmen for coming in and getting
into that support group and
sharing your wisdom and experience thank
you guys so much